all right September is hunger action
month while food insecurity can affect
anyone hungry seniors are more likely to
develop health issues such as diabetes
and even heart disease this story is
part of the channel 8 Community phone
bank where you call them with your
concerns Mary Jane beliesza reports
older residents here at the Royal mobile
park community in the Northeast Valley
say they are struggling to gain access
to food and medical care they reached
out to 8 news now for help May Simpson
lives on a fixed pension while she has
some extra cash to splurge on food she
says many of her neighbors cannot nine
out of every 10 people in this pump
can't do that they don't have the money
they don't have resources and some of
them don't even have family Simpson has
lived in this community for nine years
she feels older residents living along
Lam and Nellis are left out with no
nearby food drives or vaccination
clinics what do we have to do to
suddenly wake somebody up in county or
whoever is responsible and say Hey you
know there isn't an embarkation line
here for many seniors living alone with
no assistance and lack of Technology
skills is a barrier in finding resources
if you were to get say one day
a month even
where you could list just run them up on
the screen all the names and telephone
numbers where these people could get
assistance Alex Phillips from Three
Square Food Bank wants to bridge that
Gap by bringing groceries and fresh
produce to them through their golden
groceries program in our pantry and home
delivery options available and the
really nice part about the program is
that the only qualifier is that they
need to be 60 or older we don't ask for
income qualifications or immigration
status or anything like that
organizations like three Square are
working to bring better access to
seniors reporting from Vegas Valley
Drive and lamb mayor and Gene beliesza 8
News Now
well if you need help finding food and
are 60 years or older and need home
delivered groceries you can call Three
Square the number right there on your
screen 702-765-4030